voilà je prends pour la nouvelle année
évidemment moi qui ai une nombreuse
famille il a fallu que je distribue des
jouets et à propos des enfants je me
souviens qu'un jour on m'a demandé
on m'a dit mais vous qui avez des
enfants est ce que est ce que vous leur
dites enfin je parle pour mon aîné qui
va sur ses quinze ans maintenant et je
suis très jeune et d'embellissement faut
sauver la face alors on m'a dit mais
est-ce que vous lui avez est-ce que vous
avez pris un jour votre garçon a peur
pour lui dire dis donc voila mon vieux
comment ça se passe les choucha alors
j'aime était difficile de répondre
autrement qu'en rire alors j'ai écrit
huit petits verres que je vais vous dire
ça fait comme ça si vous avez les
garçons de 15 ans je vais vous donner
mon adresse je vous enverrai la brochure
voilà le rosier ne sait pas comment se
font les roses la lionne à des lionceaux
sans avoir rien appris et mais se
reproduire est dans l'ordre des choses
moi-même je laisse eu son combat n'ait
rien dit
j'essaie donc la nature explique et ses
mystères laissez vos enfants croire aux
enfants dans les choux ils seront en
leur temps ce qu'il convient de faire et
ce qu'ils devront faire ils le feront
sans vous